detrás de mí el hospital Militar de
Bogotá donde están siendo atendidos los
cuatro niños encontrados ayer después de
40 días perdidos en la selva y tras
sobrevivir a un accidente de avioneta ya
acompañados de sus familiares en
condición aceptable pero todavía muy
débiles ha hablado con la prensa El tío
abuelo de los niños Fidencio Valencia
por momento o sea hay que dejarlo como
quieticos pues o sea ya la presencia de
nosotros pues hace de que hay vida y
ellos están contentos al ver a nosotros
la familia además de los familiares
también ha visitado a los niños el
presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro así
como la cúpula militar de Colombia y
altos funcionarios del gobierno como
Astrid Cáceres directora del instituto
colombiano de bienestar familiar y una
de las que ha liderado el operativo de
rescate y que ha hablado para France 24
que hay que saber que que tenemos que
hacer todo por cada niño y cada niña no
Y que cuando pasa algo con los niños hay
un llamado muy importante a que a que a
que todos nos unamos para protegerlos no
no hay que demeritar ningún llamado de
ninguna voz de un niño conocida como
operación Esperanza destacado las
instituciones que nunca ha habido un
operativo como este en Colombia y con el
lema de buscarlos hasta encontrarlos se
han Unido de forma inédita militares e
indígenas así hablaba para France 24
Giovanni Julie director de la unidad de
restitución de tierras quien ha
destacado la importancia de los
conocimientos ancestrales y esta
juntanza entre la guardia indígena y los
soldados de la patria nos muestra que
cuando nos juntamos en realidad podemos
caminar por el sendero de la vida como
lo ha enseñado nuestra madre selva como
nos lo ha enseñado los Espíritus y
mayores que habitan allá y que por
supuesto hoy nos entregan a los niños
una verdadera historia de película La
vivida a las últimas semanas en la que
todos los participantes en la operación
de rescate han coincidido en que es un
mensaje de Esperanza para la infancia de
Colombia